ein entwickler drei spiele einmal müssen
sie springen einmal müssen sie fallen
einmal müssen sie kämpfen heute müssen
sie fallen und damit herzlich willkommen
mir zum zweiten teil dieser dreiteiligen
serie wie soll ich das eigentlich die
kamera etc jetzt eigentlich doch wird
ich habe ja schon im vorgestrigen video
gesagt dass es drei spiele gibt merkt
werden jake one vorneweg dämpfe und ich
hab dann vor zwei tagen dieses make the
jump gespielt und jetzt hab ich mir ich
spiele das mainboard wir fahren direkt
an bits in der reha gleich print gibt
mir vorher meinen high scores übrigens
also ich bin relativ gut und der blaue
hatte bisher ich nichts zu tun der blaue
schilder seine basis jetzt grad läuft
macht er wenn man bitten etwa fällt bei
und viele meinen dass es an nicht amor
kratzen luca hier manchmal bisschen hier
ein bisschen reiskammer von ich mache
kein high school schüler in meinem
letzten spiel gesagt nachkommen haben
gesagt acht minuten für seinen video wo
ich immer das gleiche mache ist ein
bisschen zu viel deswegen hoffe ich dass
das jetzt mal ein bisschen kürzer halte
aber ich hatte dann halt gerne aus
bettringen spielen und die will man dann
selber so dass die setzen kommt im neuen
halt gebieten
dieses abraham lincoln oder wäre es das
sorry falls ist falsch es ich bin kein
geschichts lka und hatte das auch nicht
im abitur abitur abitur direkt durch die
der weg vielleicht läuft einfach überall
dran vorbei slater weg wird steinig
schweer gestern den kommentare
geschrieben
durch die polizisten 4100 geparkt doch
klar und das werde ich hier auch wieder
schaffen ich werde hier
wenn ich sage com nachlesen wenn ich
sage dass ich fitter als 100 geschafft
habt dann mach ich das dann habe ich das
geschafft
daher können wir das durch glauben dass
ich drei tage am stück gespielt haben
echt nicht gegessen habe und ich meine
dass hier ich dachte echt immer wieder
gerne das hier wird mal ein spiel also
ich bin ja echt so fokussiert ich hab
eine neue taktik ich mich darauf
konzentriere bisschen wohler
dass ein ausweichmanöver gut oder oder
oder
sie war es nicht in einer million jahren
auf keinen fall mehr france say never
mister klettern jetzt negativ auf ein
bayer schering abraham lincoln oder in
anderer komischer typ mit bad ischl i
don't have to say just habe ich
eigentlich
man merkt richtig dass ich noch kein
englisch gerade da uni hat mir you don't
have to see me als richtig hier helfen
ich mache immer diese schnapszahlen 22
33 sehen würde ich sagen einheits
kopiert auch einfach 3333 oder ich sage
dass man jetzt schon mal dass ich im
letzten run werde ich einfach 3333
locker ich mache eben heiß mama mama
papa ich mache eben kurz danke und die
freunde da hat wirklich meine mutter mit
mir geredet da bin ich einfach in die
andere ecke des zimmers gegangen
das war wirklich meine marke nochmals
ein paar geschichten aus meinem leben
erzählen uns war war ich letztens feiern
hier in hamburg und habe so einen typen
von berlin tag & nacht getroffen keine
ahnung wer das war wer das lied das
haben sie vorne von goethe die dollar
gewinne ich gehe zudem hat es mir
vielleicht ein foto conti lieferando hd
bekommt er sogar ein video diese
arschlöcher ich hab richtig hoch hallo
lieferando ich würde gerne was bestellen
ja ja genau 2000 plätzen ging man kommt
dann wieder ein toller smiley contractor
denkt man könnte mit dem ipad
telefonieren und freunde wenn ich jetzt
unter ihnen dem facebook post von mir
see oder in die welt twitter dieses
konkreter und entweder drunter denkt man
könnte mit einem ipad telefoniert dann
hab ich die zeiten in hand gemacht juckt
mich nicht locker
44 schnaps warum immer schnapszahl ich
muss euch irgendwann glaube ich wenn ich
meinem klub see so viel aus thun alte
willkommen wir machen das ganz locker
wir machen einfach 0.1 gold 95
wie kann ich mich sehr über so eine
scheiße so freuen so des postens bei
twitter und man ich bin echt so durch
das habe auch so viele geschrieben alter
behindert ist in dieser typ der das auch
nimmt fakt dessen eltern fusel
ich wollte weg machen vergessen dass ich
dabei ja dann springe tschuldigung im
kopf rincon kommt crafter streichelt
gerne sein mikrofon max lkw kran kraft
hat mir geschrieben dass man sich für
einen spendenprogramm bei youtube in
deutschland anmelden kann dass ihr
irgendwie wenn ihr wollt für youtuber
spenden könnt verließen das dann ist ja
einfach sowas von von switch wisst ihr
da irgendwas genaueres könne mir das mal
sagen ich hab davor noch nie gehört dass
man ihnen über youtube schmecken kann
ich hab das also zumindest in
deutschland ich hab das in mexiko und
usa oder so gehört aber dass in
deutschland jetzt einfach jeder zehn
millionen euro für mich und ich mache
eben kurzen hals kanada locker easy ich
dinge mich ebenso rum sei gar kein ding
12 petit dass das hier
da hab ich gerade voll auf die
tischkante gewonnen schmerzt auch gute
bringt mich so auf aber ich brauche das
einfach wenn ich auto fahre und vom
bildschirm bitte und ihr seid hier wegen
dem spiel das weiß ich nicht wegen
meinen ganzen problemchen das sagen
letzter dir auch mal richtig viele auch
gekauft und bildgebung mit folie
unterhaltungskanal geworden ist das
jetzt schlecht oder ist das jetzt gut
ich gebe mal einfach mehr mühe dabei die
videos zu bearbeiten und hab da auch
lust dran und krieg jetzt alles seitdem
ich studiere habe ich halt so richtig
kontrolle über mein leben jetzt
mittlerweile und weiß genau wie ich mir
alles ein teil und ich glaube wenn ich
ganz viel am stück kommentiere und wenig
schneider das ist mein gott war das mal
eine brille wie ich sag's euch jeden
fall habe ich mir so gegen den kopf dass
man sehr oft als mir sonst exporten gebe
ich mir voll die brille ihnen die augen
dann habe ich einfach gucken ich habe
auch hier dieses rote teil ging
freundlich gebe es noch ein paar preis
wir müssen auch erst mal irgendwann
so ein bisschen pathos reimt sich auf
franchise hatte ich gerade gegessen wo
allokation reis gegessen
mit curry und bisschen tomaten drin
man darf mich nicht sehen dann sind die
scores meistens immer besser das heißt
ich mache das jetzt mal ganz kurz er
kann eigentlich alles nach derzeitigen
schneller wird mir kommt es am anfang
immer ich bin auch klug so wenn es nicht
schneller werden würde wäre es ja
irgendwie komisch das wäre ich bin wenn
ich ein spiel entwickelt höher die ganze
zeit ist wird von von ganz schwer zu
ganz einfach kein spaß habe ich gesagt
ich mach das ding wenn man mich nicht
wie comdirect neuer rekord bei rum
freunde ich melde mich wenn ich neuen
highscore so das ist jetzt mein finalen
score eingeblendet 2960 warm ein finaler
scorsese ein bisschen ich weiß es ein
bisschen wenig hatte jetzt natürlich
gedacht ist ist allerdings auch schon
wieder fünf stunden später und ich habe
echt wieder extrem hunger ich würde
sagen es euch gefallen hat zeigt eine
mit einer bewertung ich habe wieder lang
daran gesetzen bestimmt das ganze zu
bearbeiten hoffe ich mal also ich habe
an 1 5 stunden im einheitsgrau jetzt
gerade gesessen und dann will ich
einfach das war spiel nummer zwei von
hedge-fonds dieser make them reihe und
in zwei tagen kommt bis dahin
verabschiedung mache